tenemos ocho monedas en una bolsa de las
cuales tres de estas monedas son monedas
de truco y las otras cinco son monedas
normales las monedas de truco tienen la
trampa de que a lanzarlas al aire la
probabilidad de que salga cara en estas
monedas es de un 60% si tú eliges al
azar una de estas monedas y la lanzas el
aire dos veces cuál es la probabilidad
de que obtengas dos caras seguidas cuál
es el porcentaje de la probabilidad de
obtener dos caras seguidas y la pregunta
está bastante interesante y justo antes
de ver todo el diagrama y todo el árbol
de las probabilidades y los sucesos que
podrían pasar me gustaría que pensamos
un poco en el problema es que el
problema nos dice que tenemos cinco
monedas normales y tenemos por otra
parte tres monedas de truco voy a
dibujar aquí mil maneras normales y
después tengo una dos tres cuatro cinco
monedas contra tres monedas que son
monedas de truco
todas estas monedas se meten en una
bolsa hasta aquí vamos bien y después
vas a meter la mano dentro
todas estas monedas vas a sacar una para
lanzarla al aire dos veces pero si te
das cuenta si fueran todas normales o si
pensamos en las monedas que son
solamente normales y de ahí sacamos una
moneda y la lanzamos dos veces al aire
pues la probabilidad de obtener dos
caras pues es 50% que es la probabilidad
de sacar una cara en la moneda normal
por 50 por ciento es decir punto 50 por
punto 50 mientras que si nos fijamos en
las monedas de trucos y hacemos lo mismo
metemos la mano sacamos una y la
lanzamos dos veces al aire pues
tendríamos 60% por 60% de obtener dos
veces cara sin embargo el problema
radica y consiste en que aquí tenemos
una bolsa con monedas mezcladas por lo
tanto el problema se empieza a complicar
así que vamos a separar este problema en
dos variantes vamos a suponer en el
primer lugar que sacamos una moneda
normal y en segundo lugar vamos a
suponer que sacamos una moneda de truco
entonces tenemos dos posibles eventos
sacar una moneda normal o sacar una
moneda de truco de estas que tenemos
aquí primero pues la probabilidad de
sacar una
normal pues tenemos ocho monedas y son
cinco monedas normales por lo tanto si
nosotros queremos meter la mano y sacar
una moneda normal tenemos una
probabilidad de cinco octavos mientras
que si hacemos el razonamiento análogo
para saber cuál es la probabilidad de
meter la mano a la bolsa y sacar una
moneda que sea de truco pues va a ser
tres octavos es decir tres monedas de
truco entre ocho monedas totales y bueno
todo esto ya nos da un esquema de cuál
es la probabilidad de cuando nosotros
saquemos una moneda obtener una moneda
normal o en su dado caso obtener una
moneda de truco pero ahora la pregunta
va a ser vamos a suponer que ya estamos
en la primera rama de este árbol si ya
sacamos una moneda normal ahora cuál va
a ser la probabilidad de obtener dos
caras seguidas dado ojo dado que la
moneda que saque es una moneda normal y
bueno como es una moneda normal la
probabilidad de obtener una cara es del
50% por lo tanto de obtener dos caras es
de que la primera salga una cara y que
en la segunda también salga una cara
quiere decir 50% por 50% o dicho de otra
manera 0.50 por 0.50 lo cual me da 0.25
pues punto 5 por punto 5 es lo mismo que
punto 25 porque se recorre el punto dos
veces ojo esta es la probabilidad de
obtener dos caras dado que sacamos la
moneda normal y bueno si yo quisiera
saber la probabilidad total de esta rama
es decir la probabilidad de sacar una
manera normal y además de obtener dos
caras pues lo que tengo que hacer es
multiplicar cinco octavos por 0.25
entonces la probabilidad de todas estas
ramas para que no nos perdamos la voy a
atrapar con un cierto color entonces voy
a agarrar toda esta rama de aquí y voy a
sacar la probabilidad de toda esta rama
de aquí es decir yo lo que voy a querer
es la probabilidad de sacar una moneda
normal y además sacar dos caras esto es
cinco octavos por 0.25 cinco octavos por
0.25 y eso como lo escribimos a pues es
la probabilidad de quién
es la probabilidad de que saquemos la
moneda normal ojo yo es muy importante
es la probabilidad de que saquemos una
moneda normal y que además saquemos dos
caras por lo tanto dejen escribirlo aquí
la probabilidad de toda esta rama o de
nuestro primer escenario es la
probabilidad de obtener una moneda que
sea normal y además que en esa moneda
nos den dos caras seguidas entonces la
probabilidad de que sea normal y además
que obtengamos dos caras seguidas es lo
mismo que cinco octavos por 0.25 bueno
es una primera rama ahora si yo me fijo
en la segunda rama hasta ahorita
habíamos sacado que teníamos una
probabilidad de tres octavos que al
meter yo la mano en la bolsa saqué una
moneda que sea de truco ahora yo lo que
voy a creer es la probabilidad de
obtener dos caras seguidas dado que mi
moneda sea de truco pero bueno en el
problema dice que nosotros tenemos una
probabilidad del 60 por ciento del 60%
de que al lanzar esta moneda de truco al
aire me salga una cara por lo tanto si
yo lo que quiero son dos caras va a ser
cero puntos 60 por 0 puntos
o 60% por 60% lo cual me da 0.36 es
decir esta es la probabilidad de obtener
dos caras seguidas de obtener una cara y
después otra cara dado que ya sacamos
una moneda la cual sea una moneda de
truco entonces ahora para ello poder
calcular toda la probabilidad de esta
rama que tengo aquí abajo de mi segundo
escenario pues yo lo que quiero es la
probabilidad de obtener una moneda de
truco y además de obtener dos caras y
esto va a ser de manera análoga lo que
hicimos acá arriba pues tres octavos
quema multiplicar a 0.36 tres octavos
que va a multiplicar a la probabilidad
de obtener dos caras dado que ya tenemos
la moneda que es de truco lo cual era
0.36 y pues ahora saquemos la
calculadora para resolver estas
operaciones yo tengo cinco octavos por
0.25 cinco octavos lo voy a multiplicar
por 0.25 y esto me da punto 15 625 punto
15 625 entonces todo esto
a 0.15 625 muy bien ahora voy a calcular
la segunda probabilidad la probabilidad
de la rama de abajo que son tres octavos
que multiplica a 0.36 tres octavos por
punto 36 6.135 entonces esto es igual a
cero punto 135 pero entonces ya sacamos
que la probabilidad de la primera rama
es decir la probabilidad que la moneda
sea normal y además de obtener dos caras
es de 0.15 625 y la probabilidad de la
segunda rama es decir de obtener una
moneda que sea de truco y además de
obtener dos caras es de 0.135 ahora lo
que yo voy a buscar es la probabilidad
total de obtener dos caras es decir me
voy a fijar en la probabilidad de que en
la primera sea normal o en la
probabilidad de que la segunda sea de
truco por lo tanto cuando yo digo en
probabilidad lo que hay que hacer es
sumar estas dos probabilidades es decir
la probabilidad de sacar una manera
normal y sacar dos caras o sacar una
moneda de truco y sacar
caras es decir hay que sumar por lo
tanto vamos a sumar lo 0.135 más 0.15
625 es lo mismo que en 29 125 voy a
escribirlo aquí antes de que se me
olvide 0.29 125 y este numerito había
salido de la suma de la probabilidad de
la primera rama que era 0.15 el 625 más
0.135 que era la probabilidad de la
segunda rama es decir ya con esto
obtendría la probabilidad final y si lo
que queremos es pasarla a términos de
porcentaje me va a quedar 29 puntos 125
por ciento es decir lo único que hice
fue multiplicar por 100 y si lo que
queremos es redondear lo entonces lo
podemos ver como 29.13 por ciento y si
te das cuenta está probabilidad es un
poco mayor a la probabilidad si
tuviéramos en la bolsa puras monedas que
fueran todas normales porque en ese caso
la probabilidad de obtener dos caras
sería de 25 por ciento y en este caso
aumentó al 29 punto 13 por ciento porque
las monedas con truco tenían una
probabilidad del 60%
de caer cara y como esta es una
probabilidad mayor a la probabilidad
habitual entonces nuestra probabilidad
final nos va a salir mayor así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo